you know a lot of us too were looking at
the stars in the sky trying and trying
to see that beautiful lunar eclipse last
night we had so many clouds in the sky
though we didn't get to see it nearly as
well as some other locations so let's
just go to la if you uh if you stepped
outside last night and you were like oh
we got clouds i can't find it this is
what it looked like at the griffith
observatory in southern california
around los angeles beautiful as the
earth's shadow was overtaking the moon
and then it turned that reddish color
absolutely glorious really really pretty
there with mostly cloud-free skies in
southern california so it lasted about
an hour and a half and then the earth's
shadow moved away and it was a brilliant
super white the flower moon for may
gorgeous
i did we did get a couple of photos that
we've been sharing through the morning
and i wanted to share this one too from
nasa
ernie wright who works for nasa at
goddard space flight center took this
through their telescope their super
powered telescope there's that reddish
color cast over the moon all of the
earth sunrises and sunsets at that
instant that light refract refracts and
bends and gets thrown over the moon just
really really beautiful we've got clear
skies now we've got good sunshine out
there temperatures in the 70s remember
about a week ago we had some morning
lows in the 40s and 50s it was cool last
week you don't need a jacket this
morning it feels pretty nice out there
here your headlines breezy winds to
start and finish the week and then extra
hot temperatures between 95 and 100 most
of the week but by the time we get to
friday a stronger system will bring us
stronger winds cool us off to the 80s
but that probably will only last for
about a day it's all the first week the
beginning of the week winds are from
this front right up here to the north
it's helping to pull away the clouds
from that we had from sunday but it's
also picking up some southerly breezes
those should be about 25 miles an hour
up in the mountains today beautiful
temperatures up there at mount
charleston in the mid 70s we'll be right
back up close to 100 degrees today just
like sunday at 99 with southeasterly
breezes to about 20 miles an hour and
then tomorrow probably stronger winds a
little bit to 25 miles an hour temps go
down just a couple of degrees and then
right back up to 100 on thursday but
stronger southwest winds 30 35 miles an
hour went thursday into friday and
that's where the temperatures drop to
the 80s low 90s to start the weekend but
you can see it gets hot again to finish
the weekend back up to 102 maybe on
monday